after a particularly confusing
conversation about time slipping between
o Wilson's Mobius and TVA Tech guy or a
Boris nicknamed OB and played by kiho
Kuan the latter says wow that makes
perfect sense there's no fly in that
logic ob's demeanor is so pure his tone
so genuine and his smile so friendly
that it's almost impossible to criticize
him for being the mouthpiece of a
seemingly self-aware production team yes
the line is funny because Quan is funny
but it's also funny because it's so
obviously a moment of LP shading or
calling attention to something confusing
and then just moving on while lump
shading can be used to great effect in
the form of meta jokes it can be used to
bypass necessary narrative explanations
it feels as though Marvel Studios is
plainly informing audiences that
critical analysis will not be tolerated
and that's frustrating because again
it's coming out of Quan's mouth an
objectively talented and funny guy how
dare Loki make us feel conflicted
emotions about that man